hey everyone thank you for joining us my
name is nikki bowers i
am the social media and marketing
producer for eight news now
and i am here with cherise williams she
is a north las vegas loco and she is an
educator and she is here to tell us
about
her new children's books her books are
in stores
stories that you guys all know we'll
talk about that in a bit but first let's
just introduce
cherise right here charisse welcome
hello everyone thank you so much nikki
for having me i'm super excited to share
about my journey as a new self-published
author
and talk about my new books um
she already introduced me my name is
charisse williams i
am a licensed educator in the ccsd
clark county school district um i am
married i am currently in
italy right now with my husband and my
two kids
i have a one-year-old and a
four-year-old so
um oh so sharice your kids are they
did they inspire you to write your books
yes
absolutely so tell everyone your name
the name of the book
so my uh my first book is princess heart
so it's a princess heart series they'll
have three books to it
and then my other book is penny d
so my son's name is penny and it was
just we always call him penny d
so both of the books are definitely
based off of my children and my family
so princess heart learns to tumble and
princess heart learns to cheer
and penny d's first basketball game so
i definitely base my books off of my
children and my family
so tell us about the books tell us about
what you are hoping to
tell like teach kids and inspire kids to
do with these books
oh well first and foremost like i want
to make sure that every child that has
my books
are able to benefit from it and learn
something from it so
in my books i have a checklist that
teaches the child
certain skills that i teach when i teach
extracurricular activities like
tumbling or cheerleading or basketball
that they can
follow and learn at home from um as well
as
being able to motivate the children and
inspire them that
when it gets challenging to never give
up and continue to work hard so
i want to make sure that i'm really
pushing those um my motto for the kids
to be able to take
the things that i use in my day-to-day
and for my kids
for them to have at home as well now
sharice i know
um being a self-published author is
not an easy road how did you decide that
you wanted to self-publish and go on
this journey
and tell us about your journey how has
it been for you
okay it's definitely a journey and i'm
still
learning throughout this journey i've
only been a self-publisher for what
seven eight months now so i i published
my first book
june 10 20 last summer so june 10
2020 and now i have you know
going on four books soon to be in march
my
next princess heart but i can talk about
that later but um
the journey has just been amazing i
wanted to know the ins and outs of
publishing a book
um being the first uh children's book
writer and children's book publisher in
my family
i had no idea where to start you know so
a lot of research and a lot of
determination
to make it happen it was a dream it was
a goal
and when you're when you're doing it all
by yourself you really don't know
where to start so i had to really
um research on with the late nights
early mornings with you know having a
family and still trying to
make it happen so i started with step
one and just
writing my story step two researching
how can i bring my vision to life
and just navigating and being navigated
with the right team
and there were a lot of different
freelance people that i could speak with
and be able to use and they you know we
work together to help it to
become reality but it definitely wasn't
um an easy journey because you
speak to so many different people and
you have to choose the right people that
you're able to work with and that
you guys can definitely have a good
um business relationship to help the the
dream to become reality so
but every step of the way of it it was
so rewarding
so um you know there were a lot of
moments where i was
you know wanted to give up or you know
it was just too hard but
i knew at the end result it would be all
worth it and it definitely has been all
worth it so
so is the is the running theme of your
books um
for children is it to inspire them to go
after their dreams and never give up
no matter the obstacles that they face
absolutely no dream is sustainable and
no vision is sustainable and no
goal is sustainable so if you have a
dream
a vision or a goal and at a young age i
you know i had big dreams you know and i
was
discouraged and saying that you know you
you can't do that
you know what i mean and being told like
for me like i can't do it
it really put a toll on me and i will
never forget the person or who
and how it was said to me when i was
young in
you know elementary school and it was
you you hold on to that
and so with my books i want to just make
sure that the children know that no
matter how young you are no matter how
old you are you know
your dreams your visions or your goals
are something that you really really
want to do it's it can become reality
it's a lot of work but it can become
reality and never ever let anybody tell
you that
you can't do it at a young age so that's
that's the moral of why i'm i really
wanted to push these books
um for them to to get into as many
children's hands as i can
so definitely i love that and i also
love being a black woman and you being a
black woman
um it is black history month yes
how amazing is it that you are a black
woman
you are telling stories that feature
little black
beautiful children it is black history
month and your book is in walmart
yes it is in walmart for anyone to go
and access
and share it and show with other kids
how important was that for you to make
sure
that you created uh characters in your
book will look like your children
i i wanted um i wanted my kids to
to grow originally before i had children
my vision was
for me to be at the front of these books
and to have
a child look and say oh she looks like
me or oh
you know he looks like me or you know
what i mean so
initially when i did have children
they'll
they were my my drive to use them
as the the characters for them to
resemble other kids and for the
for them when they get older to say
oh that's me and for a child that they
read it to as they get older to say oh
that's my mom
or that that person looks like me or you
know
i wanted to to make sure that the
character that was on the front another
child can look at it and say oh she has
curly hair just like me
or she's brown just like me or you know
her eyes are big just like me you know
what i mean so
just wanting the child to look at the
cover at the character and say
wow that person looks like me so it's
an amazing feeling and you know being a
black woman
and being able to uh inspire
other kids and not only other kids but
you know other women
and other men as well i've helped you
know a few other um
new men and women as self-published
author and
they have beautiful black children on
the front of their book
and now they can take that and use that
as a legacy
um a legacy it's a legacy because this
never dies and i'm like that's what
we're creating collect great
legacy for our kids our kids kids our
kids kids kids kids
they see it they say oh yes that you
know my mom did it or my grandma did it
and when they
read it to their kids or their kids
friends
they look just like me so that's why
yeah
so um i love that i love that um
so what are some of the messy other
messages that
parents can expect for their kids to
learn in these books
now not only do i target the
children in the book to motivate and
inspire them
every book that i write it has messages
behind them not only for the children
but also for the parents because it's
for me it's very important for to have
that parent
involved in some sort even if it's a
small talk
at the table to motivate them and to
just give them that extra push that they
would need
to do it you know some kids they think
that um
oh i really really really want to do it
but then they have a child at school
that says
what you know you you you can't do that
like you're not you're not good enough
or why you know and then children start
to think of what other people think but
having the parent
come and sit and just have that that
relationship or that one talk with their
child
it can really take them a long way to
say my mom believes in me if nobody
believes in me
so in every book that i write i always
want to make sure that the parent
is involved with that child or you know
that child
but the parent is involved with the
character and for them to make sure
that you know they're using their um
motivation and talks with them to help
them
become great and beyond great and
whatever it is whether it's
tumbling cheerleading basketball or even
activities in school
or anything else they would like to do
so i definitely target both and that's
my purpose having like
penny d his father is very very involved
and motivating him
to work hard be dedicated be determined
for you to make the basketball team
for princess heart she comes through so
many different challenges and so many
obstacles that make a child say i don't
want to do it anymore it's too hard
mom says no you can do it so what do you
do to do it and it gives them certain
certain ideas for them to want to do it
and
to continue to do it and then be great
at it when they do it
so all of my books have messages behind
them for the parents as well for the
child
both i love that i love that i think
that's very important because
i think it's very important that parents
can see themselves in the book too
because a parent who may not know to be
as encouraging
um you know because a lot of people may
not know that they should be as
encouraging to their children
that is important in development they
can look at that and they give a little
lesson without feeling like they're
being shamed or anything they just kind
of
look at it and they're like oh you know
i could be a little bit more
encouraging give my kids a little bit
more of a push and
let them know that they can do whatever
they put their minds to it so that's
great that you did that
thank you so much thank you so um you
talked about
um how you've had people tell you
things that you can't accomplish you
know um
adults and when you were a child is that
one of the other reasons why you
wholeheartedly wanted to put all of your
heart into this
as a passion project because you
remember what that felt like as a kid
absolutely that is my number one
inspiration the reason why
and i've always been passionate about
youth and making that positive
impact in youth and being that if if not
that one person that that child can
trust and that that child can
say you know miss at the time miss
samuel can believe in me i miss williams
now but miss samuel
she believes in me or miss cherise she
believes in me so i know that i can come
and talk to her if i feel discouraged so
being told no or being told i'm too
young to accomplish a goal or a dream
that i had was too big
at a young age it definitely put a toll
on me to
where i'm at now and if it didn't it
wasn't a negative toll it was
the toll that i needed the target that i
needed to push me
yeah to making my dreams and my visions
and goals reality i wish i could go back
and say
look at here like i i graduated
uh you know with a ba at 21 years old i
graduated with a master's at 22 you know
but i use that as my motivation to to
keep pushing and to just say
i don't want a child to feel the way
that i felt at a young age
so if i can do anything in my power to
motivate
encourage inspire them to be great and
to
to be um just
amazing in all that they're do they do
this was just another another avenue i
you know
it was another way to target many and
many of children
um to not be average don't let me
give up don't be just okay be great
and try for greatness absolutely so yes
that definitely was my
number one inspiration and had me to
push to make it happen
so okay so obviously since you are
an arthur rest um
i have to say that in my mind i had to
say it in my maya voice from girlfriends
remember girlfriends
i love it yeah i love that author i love
that you're unauthorized
um what you obviously grew up reading
books and loving books so what was your
favorite book as a child
and did you have inspiration from that
in creating your
you know and it's funny because i'm
gonna be honest i wasn't a reader
you know i wasn't a reader um it didn't
engage me it didn't
um it books really the certain books
didn't keep me engaged when i
found a book that um
kept me excited and wanting to know next
or what's gonna happen next
that's when i that's when i started to
really read
um and that's another part of why i
wanted to read books
you know what i wanted to write books
because i wanted the most
interesting and relatable to life
situations i get that
that's why and when i read a couple of
books or when i started to i was just
like you know
i read it and then no but if i did have
you know a book i read this book every
day you know clifford's book i love
you know his series clifford the big red
dog
my son has every book and i read it all
the time and
i just love how he keeps the children
engaged and wanting
to know more and definitely an
inspiration to make
make sure i say okay i want to make sure
my kids are engaged or
whoever reads the book are engaged and
wanting to want more from
my story so yeah how old are your kids
i have a four-year-old he'll be five in
march and then a one-year-old who's
two in march so we're all for march baby
too
i'm a march baby too march 9th march 11.
that's why you got that good energy
it's always relatable we always feed off
of each other we do
and look the spirits are always genuine
they are
very genuine definitely so are you
excited that because your baby
your your four-year-old is around the
age where she she's going to
be starting to read right four-year-old
the boy or the girl my son is four and
my daughter is born
oh okay so are you excited are you
excited when they
are going to be able to read this like
i'm excited about that for you that's
what you know
my son he's already um he's already
memorizing books so you know really you
can have a
like a clifford book and read and put to
the words and read it so
i used to read penny b's book he was
like mom can you read princess hearts
book and i'm like okay like
so it feels good to see them wanting to
read it so the day that they can
actually open the book on their own and
read it
i'm going to drop another tear like when
i release them
oh you're totally going to cry you're a
pisces you're going to cry
very emotional yeah so do you
does he understand that the penny d
is him like you made that for him yes
she says if i wish she was here she'll
come and i say
who's this she says that's princess
heart who's princess heart
that's paris oh they
they definitely i wanted them to know
that this is you and
when they get older they'll always have
a children's book
to remind them to be determined and yeah
give up and to work hard and all that
they do so
it's it's supe it's such a blessing i'm
super super
um overly joy with just everything
that's happening with you yeah
such a short amount of time i know six
months
was there a pandemic that motivated you
to get on it
no and that's right and before the
pandemic i was writing before the
pandemic
everything it was all before the
pandemic and
it's it's just amazing you know the
for me i started writing in 2015 um
all of my my books and
just so happened the drive to be
determined to
figure out ways to make it happen which
is the illustrations and bring it to
life because the writing part
is easy you know and just learning how
to format it and
just being knowledgeable on how margins
and just so many different terminology
when it comes to
um published books or books in general i
learned
so much like i was in school again um
so it definitely uh it was before the
pandemic
it was a journey and i was determined to
make it happen
uh being overseas you have nothing but
time
to really help bring dreams to reality
and research and learn
so yeah i love that i love that so what
else is on your book
your bucket list list as far as being an
author is concerned
so much okay so um i'm actually in the
i'm gonna finish their series that's
number one on my list i'm gonna finish
their series
um i'm actually getting ready to finish
princess well princess heart series is
actually getting done it should be done
within another month or so it's princess
because you have cheerleading and you
have tumbling
and then tell us the last one
i'm going to tell you hip-hop dance
hip-hop dance so it's a dance book but
it's a hip-hop book not an average dance
book a hip-hop dance book so
um i'm gonna finish all the series
for their books and i definitely want to
do an animation and bring them to life
so i'm i wrote the the production for it
and everything so as now it's just
managing and
um really trying to
make sure that you know the the
animation it speaks to them and
not you know i wanted to make sure that
everyone can relate to it but see that
a black family together doing this
together like yeah
it's it's just remarkable so
that as well as i'm gonna you know
because we're getting it out now i'm
also um going to i'm going to but i
i put together a children's book
coast-to-coast
children's book expo for authors other
authors like me so we can
um you know share read and really
uh push us as black authors and
you know not even black but hispanic and
asians just yeah
we really don't see on a day-to-day
basis or the light that we see i really
want to
help other authors um not just settle
but really
expand their brand and really push them
so
i'm launching that you know hopefully if
covet it allows us to do it
july i mean june and july of this year
so i'm really excited about that
as well as i really want to start
helping other
authors who have you know other people
who have dreams of being authors
children's book authors to help them um
through their journey
to make their dream or go reality as
well so that's those are on my bucket
list to complete
um you know once i finish my my books
and i want to be able to help others and
really help blossom our you know us
show what we can do we all write we can
write amazing stories
so yeah and every story that i've read
from black author
children book authors that i've you know
had interests for this coast-to-coast
expo all are different and they're all
are amazing and they all have empowering
messages behind them so
i'm really really excited to see what
2021 is going to do for me this year
it's gonna do great things i can feel it
you have an amazing spirit
and personality and these books are so
cute i'm like i'm gonna go buy one even
though i'm not i don't have kids but i
kind of want to
i want to read them what they're about
i love all the pink and i love her
little pom-poms in her hair
hello when i come to vegas i'm gonna
sign you one
you know okay personal letter for you so
you can have it so thank you
thank you well you are amazing and um
thank you so much for letting us
interview and interview you and talking
about your journey you know i think
it's going to help a lot of people who
maybe want to go down this road and who
maybe
are scared and so it's going to give
them a little push
so even you know outside your books you
are inspiring people to go after their
dreams
thank you so much for you and just
taking the time out to interview me and
you guys just wanting me to
share my story and my journey um
i really really appreciate it and i hope
this
you know this interview and this story
inspires others and
children and and other people who want
to make a dream goal or vision reality
make it reality you know yes yes
you can do it you know and there's
actually a lot of work and dedication
but it's possible
and you know we can do it and so
i love it charisse tell everyone where
they can find you on
social media and if you have a website
absolutely so
you can find me on my penny d underscore
well it's princess heart underscore
penny d
books on instagram princess heart and
penny b
books on facebook princess heart
affinity books on twitter
um or you can go to my website www
dot princess heart and penny b books at
site.com
um all of my books are on amazon barnes
and noble goodreads bookmate
walmart so go to walmart's website order
your
and copy support support i hope you guys
like them
um i hope you guys continue to stay on
this
uh princess heart and penny d journey
with me and see what all is going to
happen next
yes uh thank you so much
thank you all right so you guys make
sure you go check her out go check her
out on all her websites we'll definitely
put it in the article too
and make sure you check her out on
amazon uh check out
princess heart the princess heart series
and the penny b
series on amazon and in walmart and
in you said borders right barnes and
noble
yeah yes all right thank you charisse
thank you nikki take care be safe out
there i hope to meet you in person
very soon